Thank You secretary for coming in and
offering your testimony under the
subpoenas that we issued to DHS your
office has produced to this committee
data showing that child separations
skyrocketed after your zero tolerance
policy went into effect more than 2,000
children were separated from their
parents in the two months following your
memo that secretary Neilson accepted
some for more than a year in
taking these decisions around family
separation and child separation did you
all consider the emotional and mental
impact on CBP officers in forcing them
to take children away from their mothers
and fathers so we absolutely consider
the well-being of our professionals who
are strained with a crisis they're
facing their strained with the stories
they're hearing of the dangers of the
journey the the abuse of women and girls
and even the process of getting to
United States thank you and do you
believe but did you did you consider the
human
effect on the officers specifically in
child separation in forcing them to take
children away from their parents
enforcing the law often has emotional
impacts for everybody involved and
that's something that they sign up for
but it's something we want to provide
brazilian services mental health support
for anyone who needs it okay and do you
do you agree with the federal court's
decision that halted your child
separation policy I agree with the
president's executive order on June 20th
last year that of course that we've
followed the federal court order
assiduously there have been reports that
President Trump and Stephen Miller
wanted to restart mass child separations
earlier this year but top DHS officials
including secretary Neilson told them
that this would violate the court order
is that true so the president said that
that zero tolerance prosecutions of
adults crossing with families is not on
the table at this time so so you are
saying that it's incorrect the reports
are incorrect saying that the president
wanted to restart child separation I'm
referring to the president's public
statements on this issue but privacy
considered in so in your experience the
answer's no
did not consider restarting child
separation first of all I'm not gonna
speak about conversations with the
president that I personally had I'm not
aware of other deliberations between
other officials um mr. secretary there
were reports that the president offered
you a pardon for closing the border to
asylum seekers according to a CNN report
senior administration officials told CNN
that President Trump told you he would
grant you a pardon if you were sent to
jail for having border agents block
asylum seekers from entering the u.s.
and defiance of US law is that correct
yeah testified about this answer this
rush in the media I've never been asked
to do anything unlawful by the President
or anyone else nor would I okay thank
you mr. secretary are you aware of the
ProPublica report indicating that there
were about 10,000 potential current and
former CBP officers in the violently
racist and sexist Facebook group I am
aware of the ProPublica article yes did
you see any of the posts in the report I
did
did you see the posts mocking migrant
children's deaths I did did you see the
post planning physical harm to myself
and congresswoman Escobar yes
directed an investigation within minutes
of reading the article did you see the
images of officers circulating
photoshopped images of my violent rape
yes I did
are those officers on the job today and
responsible for the safety of migrant
women and children so there's an
aggressive investigation on this you
should issue proceeding you've heard the
chief of the Border Patrol the most
senior female official and law
enforcement across the entire country
say that these posts do not meet our
standards of conduct and they will be
followed up aggressively
we put individuals on administrative
duties I don't know which ones
correspondent in which post and we've
issued cease desist orders to dozens and
more okay do you think that the policy
of child separation could have
contributed to a dehumanizing culture
within CBP that contributes and kind of
spills over into other areas of conduct
we do not have a dehumanizing culture at
CBP this is an agency that rescues 4,000
people a year
that's absolutely committed to the
well-being of everyone that they
interact with and obviously there's a
dehumanizing call mr. secretary I'm so
you don't think that having ten
thousand officers in a violent racist
group sharing rape memes of members of
Congress points to any concern of a
dehumanized culture congressman those
posts are unacceptable they're being
investigated but I don't think it's fair
to apply them to the entire organization
or that even the members of that group
believed or supported those posts mr.
secretary just one last thing how did
10,000 members join this group including
including I believe the head of CBP
um I'll double-check including the CBP
chief how were they in this Facebook
group without anybody knowing without
anyone in leadership now again this is a
subject of an ongoing investigation if
there was supervisory knowledge of
unacceptable activities that will also
be considered and followed up on I thank
you very much